[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv 78
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez pour
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale tout de suite les titres de ce
lundi 13 mai du en cours un nouveau
maire françois morton 49 ans était lui
hier lors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire il succède à marie
christine le tarnec démissionnaire pour
raisons de santé
françois morton est notre invité sur ce
plateau également la sénatrice les
républicains des yvelines martha de
sidra qu'elle fait partie des 248
parlementaire a signé le projet et de
référendum d'initiative partagée contre
la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
c'est une mesure phare de la loi pacte
c'est le conseil constitutionnel vient
de donner son feu vert à la procédure de
référendum
et puis c'est notre fil rouge tout cette
semaine focus sur le football féminin
dans les yvelines à quelques semaines de
la coupe du monde
elle se tiendra en france du 7 juin au 7
juillet nous irons justement ce soir à
croissy sur seine qui va accueillir des
sélections comme celle des bleus ou
encore des américaines championnes en
titre
cette information d'abord pour débuter
ce journal un prêtre de versailles mise
en examen plusieurs chefs d'accusation
d'accusation dont viol agressions
sexuelles sur mineurs et harcèlement
moral les faits remontent à 2017
le prêtre avait alors été placé en garde
à vue depuis la révélation de la sphère
à l'été 2010 8 ce prêtre ne peut plus
exercer de manière publique en france et
à l'étranger le diocèse de versailles
lui a également lu ar également retiré
son pouvoir de confesser cette mise en
examen
elle va permettre une enquête plus
approfondie souvenez vous les images
avaient fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
est choqué des lycéens agenouillé mains
sur la nuque interpellé par la police en
marge d'une manifestation à mantes la
jolie le 6 décembre dernier
aujourd'hui les premières auditions de
lycéens ont débuté l'igpn la police des
polices a ouvert une enquête
cent cinquante deux jeunes avaient été
arrêtés certains ont dénoncé des
violences commises par les forces de
l'ordre
une quarantaine de familles et des
associations comme sos racisme ont porté
plainte
elle parle notamment de violation de
liberté individuelle ou d' insultes à
caractère raciste
première invitée avec moi dans ce
journal françois morton bonsoir bonsoir
messieurs canal et vous êtes donc le
vos mères de guyancourt maire divers
gauche vous avez tués --des été élu hier
lors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire vous succéder à marie
christine le tarnais qui est
démissionnaire pour raisons de santé
votre réaction déjà au lendemain de
cette élection
quelle est elle bah écoutez c'était
d'abord un grand moment d'émotion
évidemment mais c'était important de
pouvoir régulariser une situation
effectivement de d'intérim et je
remercie évidemment le conseil municipal
de m'avoir accordé sa confiance c'est
important et nous étions d'ailleurs hier
à ce conseil municipal je vous propose
tout de suite de regarder ce sujet de
mélanie poquet de nicolas d'andrus à 49
ans françois morton devient maire de
guyancourt le troisième de ce mandat
après les démissions de françois de
ligné en 2016 et celle de marie
christine le tarnec le 15 avril dernier
une nouvelle personne mais une
continuité dans la politique municipale
elle s'inscrit tout à fait dans la
continuité de mes prédécesseurs et
notamment de même le tarnec nous sommes
à la fois dans une période où il reste
en ont même un peu moins et il n'empêche
nous avons encore un projet de ville à
clore donc ce sera évidemment ma
priorité
parmi ces projets la rénovation du mail
des saules engagé depuis l'année
dernière
l'ouverture de la résidence
intergénérationnelle au deuxième
semestre 2010 9 ou encore les travaux de
la place du marché pour son élection le
nouveau premier magistrat de la ville a
obtenu 26 voix
de son côté le conseiller municipal
olivier paréja à voter blanc
les gens ont vraiment envie de
participer et aujourd'hui beaucoup de
projets ne sont pas co-construit ne sont
pas
sont concertés a posteriori une fois que
le projet déjà démarré et la deuxième
chose c'est l'urgence climatique en fait
on ne voit pas dans nos collectivités
locales que ce soit guyancourt que ça
soit l'agglo d'inflexion et là il ya
vraiment quelque chose à faire au sein
de l'opposition anika blanc et jean luc
ariane n'ont pas pris part au vote
il me paraît pas normal de ces
passations de pouvoirs entre amis qui
dure depuis longtemps et mieux en cours
à propos des élections municipales de
2020 françois morton sera présent et
souhaitent y prendre une part active et
le nouveau maire de guyancourt françois
morton est avec moi en plateau je vous
fais juste rebondir sur la fin de ce
reportage vous avez l'intention de
poursuivre votre mandat au delà c'est de
vous représenter dès 2020 pour ces
élections municipales par écouter ma
priorité au moment où nous parlons nous
sommes au mois de mai 2019 les élections
municipales sont en mars 2020 ma
priorité en tant que maire est
évidemment de pouvoir terminer un
programme sur lequel pour lequel les
habitants de guyancourt nous ont donné
leur confiance en mars 2014
donc j'ai ce programme vous avez 11 mois
vous allez vous placez justement dans
cette continuité celle de françois de
lignes et de marie-christine l'internet
vous l'avait dit et c'est absolument
donc je suis évidemment dans une
continuité
il nous reste un certain nombre de
projets encore une fois terminée qui
sont des projets importants
certains ont été rappelés dans votre
reportage je pense aux mailles des
soldes je pense à la générale à la
maison intergénérationnelle
effectivement mais aussi la place du
marché qui va débuter au mois de
novembre les les salles d'arts martiaux
aussi qu'ils sont une attente importante
des habitants de bus en cours également
à la rentrée prochaine c'est à dire nous
moi ya encore beaucoup de projets pour
que le mirail et beaucoup de travail
voilà quel regard vous portez justement
sur ces deux ans passés à la tête du
conseil municipal de marie-christine
d'internet alors marie-christine le
tarnec s'est investi totalement durant
ces deux ans j'ai été à ses côtés
puisque j'étais son premier adjoint
donc elle s'est investie totalement on
lui a vu beaucoup de pugnacité aussi
bien pour défendre lui en cours et les
habitants de la ville de guyancourt à
tous les niveaux j'ai envie de dire au
niveau de l'agglomération au niveau de
l'état je pense est effectivement la
ligne
du métro par exemple qui a été un des
grands sujets qu'elle a pu traiter la
ligne 18 effectivement avec la gare de
guyancourt mais aussi dans les instances
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
et effectivement elle a fait en sorte
que lui en cours puissent se faire
respecter c'était important et est ce
qu'on peut dire que la tâche n'était pas
simple parce qu'elle succéder à françois
de ligne et qui a passé 14 ans comme
maire de gaillan p lâche n'était pas
simple entre elles si j'attendais que ça
n'était effectivement pas simple ça
n'était effectivement pas simple mais
tout le monde effectivement et encore
une fois les habitants du en cours nous
ont élu avec près de 68% des suffrages
en mars 2014 et aux élus une équipe et
cette équipe allait rester stables alors
effectivement voilà le contexte a fait
que marie-christine de ternay qu'a pris
la suite de françois de ligne et j'ai
pris la suite de de marie-christine le
tarnec mais nous sommes dans une totale
continuité
on rappel c'est en novembre 2016 que
françois de ligne avait démissionné
justement trois maires en cinq ans sur
le lait même mandature municipale est ce
que vous n'avez pas peur que ça en moins
lisible l'action municipale menée mais
depuis à 2014
est-ce que c'est pas une crainte que
vous avez une crainte est grande crainte
non je pense qu'il est il est important
d'expliquer les choses mme françois des
lignées avait en son temps expliqué les
raisons de son départ et encore ça
n'était pas un départ total puisque
françois des lignes est encore à nos
côtés comme marie-christine le tarnec je
vais encore principe absolument donc
j'ai envie de dire voilà c'est ce sont
les conditions c'est le contexte
daniela mardi lors d'un petit discours
en préambule daniel lamarre qui est ma
collègue adjoint kim a remis l'écharpé
hier lors du conseil municipal a
expliqué que c'était effectivement le
conseil municipal qui élisent et les
maires et nous en reparlerons en mars
2020 voilà pris que répondez vous
justement à ce qu'on a pu entendre de la
part de jean-louis cariat élus
d'opposition qui dit que finalement
cette élection votre élection c'est
n'est qu'une passation de pouvoir entre
amis c'est ses propos qu'est ce que vous
lui rien de sont effectivement ces
propos je lui laisse la responsabilité
totale de ses propos si vous avez bien
entendu ce que j'ai pu dire hier en
conseil municipal ce que je souhaite
c'est que le conseil municipal et je
pense que c'est une attente forte des
habitants de la ville de guyancourt mais
dans un contexte plus l'âge on l'a vu
par le contexte national que les débats
notamment dans ce type d'instance soit
des soit réellement des échanges de
points de vue
pourquoi pas programmatique nous allons
entrer dans une période de campagne
c'est une évidence pour tout le monde
mais il n'empêche que ça serait bien
qu'on puisse effectivement avoir une
certaine hauteur des échanges de points
de vue au sein même de votre majorité
puisque olivier parent et jacky siège
dans la majorité a lui voté blanc donc
ça veut dire qu'il est aussi du débat au
sein d'un morceau lui ment et je peux
parfaitement comprendre la position
d'olivier paréja qui par ailleurs est et
est avec nous dans la plupart des points
que nous que nous votons et avec qui
nous avons des échanges souvent
constructif ça n'est pas la question et
je lui laisse maintenant olivet paréja
de parcé sensibilité particulièrement
sensible à un certain nombre d'éléments
de de la vie des habitants de guyancourt
et je peux comprendre qu'il puisse
considérer qu'on ne va jamais assez loin
mais y'a pas de soucis merci françois
morton nouveau maire divers gauche de
guyancourt élus donc hier lors d'un
conseil municipal extraordinaire
nancy avait autre élection les
européennes qui sont programmés dans
moins de deux semaines c'est le dimanche
26 mai les représentants d'une dizaine
de listes candidates étaient hier à
fontenay le fleury pour présenter leurs
engagements sur le climat
un débat à l'invitation de l'association
papier forêt pour alerter sur l'urgence
de la situation
l'union européenne est le troisième
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre au
monde des émissions qui ne cessent
d'augmenter alors qu'elle devrait
décroître
conformément aux accords de la coop 21 à
paris et les propos sont recueillis par
mélanie poké tous les signaux sont au
rouge
les scientifiques nous alertent déjà
depuis plus 20 ans et là ça devient
catastrophique parce qu'on est dans la
dernière limite pour pouvoir nous
remettre sur des bonnes trajectoires
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
les élections européennes était
finalement un peu une bonne occasion de
remettre cet enjeu
la hauteur de laquelle il doit être au
sein des élections et puis de montrer de
faire un peu pression sur les
différentes parties pour montrer que la
société civile attend maintenant que le
monde politique se bouge vraiment
important d'aller au débat avec les
citoyens
l'élection européenne a lieu tous les
cinq ans l'europe a droit à son grand
débat une fois tous les cinq ans et il
est important dans cette dernière ligne
droite de la campagne d'aller à la
rencontre d'expliquer le programme de
répondre aux interrogations d'écouter
aussi le point de vue des citoyennes et
des citoyens
je crois que c'est important de
dialoguer avec les associations de
terrain qui sont mobilisés sur cette
question écologique et finalement depuis
quelques années le niveau de conscience
des citoyens sur les urgences
écologiques a beaucoup progressé et je
crois que c'est grâce à ce genre
d'association nous mêmes politiques on a
beaucoup appris de tout ça donc on a
besoin de ce dialogue fécond cet
établissement de la boissière école sata
justement à proposer une agriculture
plus respectueuse de l'environnement et
aussi du bien-être animal
la ferme de la tramblais reçu l'avis de
jérémy decerle il est agriculteur est en
quatrième position sur la liste
renaissance aux européennes
regroupant notamment la république en
marche et le modem un déplacement en
compagnie de la députée du secteur
aurore bergé suivie d'une table ronde
avec plusieurs acteurs du monde agricole
sud yvelinois l'interview est au micro
de michael et demi d'euros edgard pisani
disait qu'on aura besoin de toutes les
agricultures du monde pour nourrir le
monde
là c'est une manière de faire de
l'agriculture avec voilà beaucoup de
nouvelles méthodes beaucoup de nouvelles
pratiques beaucoup d'expérimentation et
qui fait finalement bon et fait donc
dans ce que comme on revient de le dire
dans ce que nous voulons construire avec
la liste renaissance finalement
réconciliés l'agriculture l'écologie
mais aussi l'économie parce que ça fait
vivre aussi un territoire sacré des sans
emploi et ça maintient finalement aussi
une certaine dynamique dans nos bras
dans nos territoires peut-être un peu
plus ruraux le conseil constitutionnel a
donné son feu vert jeudi les sages ont
validé l'ouverture d'une procédure de
rip référendum d'initiative partagée
contre la privatisation d'aéroports de
paris
cette proposition de
et faire un dom émane de 248
parlementaires dont vous faites partie
martha de sea dragon soir bonsoir
vous êtes sénatrice les républicains des
yvelines et vous avez apporté votre
soutien
à ce rythme tout comme le député les
républicains michel vialay qui est
également des yvelines alors rappelons
juste le contexte cette privatisation
est prévue par la loi pacte qui a été
adoptée le 11 avril dernier l autorise
l'état à vendre une partie ou la
totalité de ses actifs dans l'entreprise
aéroportuaire soit un peu plus de 50%
des parts qui représente 9 milliards et
demi d'euros environ alors dans les
yvelines le groupe à la gestion à des
aérodromes de toussus-le-noble ch a mené
chavenay villepreux et saint cyr l'école
cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel martha décidera comment
vous l'avez accueillis alors écoutez je
les ai accueillis avec beaucoup de joie
parce que sinon je n'aurais pas signé
bien évidemment cette demande qui a été
faite et conjointe avec beaucoup de
parlementaires qu'ils soient de droite
ou de gauche comme vous l'avait indiqué
dans vos propos préliminaires
il était important à un moment donné
d'envoyer un message fort en fait à
l'exécutif pour leur dire que la prime
était la privatisation d'avp aujourd'hui
il ne faut pas la faire
il ne faut pas la faire même beaucoup de
nos collègues qui n'ont pas été
signataire de
de cette demande là son partage cet avis
là c'est ça qu'il faut avoir aussi en
tête commencent à vos collègues sénateur
des yvelines vous êtes la seule service
alors qu'ils ne viennent pas que nos
collègues sénateur des yvelines y
compris des sénateurs d'autres
départements mais aussi des députés
d'autres circonscriptions
simplement aujourd'hui il y avait eu le
sujet entre nous à savoir devions nous
nous associer tous quels que soient nos
couleurs politiques à une même demande
en fait à une même action forte ou pas
dont chacun en son âme et conscience
selon son positionnement politique a
souhaité ou pas signé donc cette
proposition qui émanait donc des
socialistes je les fais parce que je
pense que comme je voulais dit il est
important d'envoyer un message fort
on ne parle pas d'une petite entreprise
on parle d'une entreprise qui est un
véritable hub au rap et un deuxième en
europe aujourd'hui peut-être premier
demain donc il était important que la
france enfin que l'état français reste
dans cette danse est belle entreprise de
manière forte et visible
avez-vous pensé c'est ce qui a fait
pencher la balance du côté des sages de
valider ce serait le fait qu'ils aient
voilà plusieurs couleurs politiques qui
qui s'associent pour pour porter ce
projet de riz alors on pourrait dire oui
mais je j'espère que nos sages du
conseil constitutionnel surtout regarde
les textes et respecte les textes ce qui
a été le cas de la démarche puisque
certains justement disait que ça
risquait de ne pas aboutir car nous
l'avions déposé à la veille du vote de
la loi pâques puisque vous savez qu'il
ya quelques quelques contraintes qu'il
faut respecter
donc les sages l'ont voté les sages
l'ont accepté parce que les règles ont
été respectées et donc il n'ya rien je
dirais d'étonnant à cela si ce n'est
évidemment les débats qui pouvait y
avoir autour du sujet on précise que
c'est la première utilisation de ce riz
pain depuis sa création en 2008 sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
vous parliez d'envoyer un message fort à
l'exécutif alors le processus de
privatisation est pour le moment stopper
le gouvernement s'est dit inquiet sur
cette décision des sages site si à
chaque fois que la majorité vote une loi
185 parlementaires peuvent retarder son
application alors cela créerait une
situation dangereuse pour la conduite de
l'action publique a déploré matignon
dans un une déclaration à al
fps que sur le coup on peut dire que le
gouvernement est mauvais joueur alors il
parle de 185 parlementaires y en a en
réalité 248 qui ont sinistré dans les
textes en fait pour pouvoir enclencher
arripe il faut 185 parlementaires
signataires nous nous avons été un peu
plus nombreux
comme vous l'avez rappelé mais je ne
pense pas qu'il faille avoir peur en
réalité 185 parlementaire sur 925 que
nous sommes ce n'est pas non plus un
seul facile à franchir à chaque fois
donc je crois que tous les garde-fous
dans le texte existe mais on va de toute
façon débattre ou savez il va y avoir
une réforme qui va se poser à nous au
niveau du parlement
donc ce sera l'occasion aussi pourquoi
pas d'assouplir certaines règles du rip
ou au contraire d'en introduire de
nouvelles à nous après de faire notre
travail de parlementaire complètement
vous parliez de faire des raisons pour
lesquelles vous êtes opposé à cette
privatisation alors il ya d'autres
exemples je pensais à toulouse blagnac
dont l'actionnaire majoritaire est un
consortium chinois l'on parle sur place
d'un aéroport embellie avec un trafic un
nombre de passagers en progression il
n'ya pas aussi des avantages dans la
privatisation
il peut toujours y avoir des avantages
et peut toujours y avoir des
inconvénients le sujet c'est d'avoir la
bonne balance et d'avoir le bon
équilibre
adp n'est pas un petit comme je vous le
disais on n'est pas une petite
entreprise européen ias voilà il n'ya
pas non plus de pertes ce n'est pas une
entreprise déficitaire parce qu'on
pourrait aussi se poser la question à
l'aune en fait des finances un tout
simplement que ceux qui sont difficiles
aujourd'hui donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
si l'état devait se dessaisir de adp ce
serait véritablement une erreur
stratégique puisque c'est stratégique à
la fois pour notre pays en termes de
souveraineté mais ceci même stratégique
d'un point de vue financier puisque
aujourd'hui la vraie le vrai sujet pour
nous c'est comment baisser les dépenses
de l'état et ne pas faire des one shots
et se dessaisir de quelque chose qui
effectivement pourrait rapporter à un
moment donné quelques recettes à l'état
mais que l'on perdrait par la suite ce
serait un véritable erreur le feu vert
du conseil constitutionnel ouvre
désormais la voie à un long processus
alors ce processus pardon pouvant
conduire à la consultation de la
population vous avez désormais neuf mois
pour recueillir par voie électronique
l'approbation d'au moins 10 % du corps
électoral français
ça représente environ 4,7 millions de
personnes
comment vous comptez y parvenir alors on
va en parler nous allons discuter
puisque la nouvelle est tombée en fin de
semaine dernière donc c'est encore trop
récent il va y avoir effectivement un
certain nombre des changes de réunion et
vous me reposerai la question dans
quelques temps et je saurais vous
répondre très précisément
quoi qu'il en soit maintenant la balle
est effectivement dans le camp de cette
démarche le dire comme ça et il va
falloir effectivement mobiliser nos
concitoyens les sensibiliser mais
surtout leur faire comprendre l'intérêt
de faire cette démarche là à nos côtés
va falloir faire de la pédagogie auprès
des français
expliquer quel est l'enjeu on ne veut ce
n'est pas on n'est pas dans une démarche
en tout cas pour ma part je ne suis pas
dans une démarche d'opposition purs et
durs comme certains auraient pu le
penser comme certains l'ont dit pour un
certain nombre de parlementaires
signataires
on est véritablement là dans une
interrogation
s'agissant de notre souveraineté et de
ses de cette belle entreprise qu'il ne
faut pas laisser j'ai envie d'y repartir
ailleurs sans pouvoir avoir un droit de
regard sur elle dernière question vous
avez bon espoir que cette privatisation
d adp soit définitivement abandonnée par
le gouvernement
je vous me posez une question difficile
espoir non je dirais là on a du travail
parce que neuf mois c'est long mobiliser
nos concitoyens c'est long donc je ne
pense pas que ce sera facile
je suis parfaitement conscient de cela
mais pour autant il ne faut pas se
décourager il faut aller jusqu'au bout
d'exercice merci martin de sidrac
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau le
sport à présent et du football la coupe
du monde féminine se tient bientôt c'est
du 7 juin au 7 juillet en france et à
cette occasion notre dossier de la
rédaction est consacrée cette semaine au
football féminin dans les yvelines
premier sujet ce soir à croissy sur
seine le stade municipal va accueillir
quatre sélections nationales
participantes au mondial le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros les stars du
football vont à nouveau fouler cette
pelouse deux ans après l'euro 2016 et la
venue de l'équipe de russie
croissy-sur-seine sera la seule ville
évinoise accueillir des sessions
d'entraînement des équipes nationales
pour la coupe du monde féminine
une décision prise en avril dernier par
la fifa et le comité d'organisation
c'est une surprise non c'est la
continuation de ce qu'on avait
engagé avec l'euro 2016 et puis l'équipe
d'angleterre n'avait appris qui est venu
s'entraîner ici
donc effectivement on avait candidaté
pour la coupe du monde au total quatre
équipes nationales vont s'entraîner sur
le site à partir du 3 juin l'afrique du
sud l'ecosse et surtout la dream team
américaine trois fois vainqueur de
l'édition est tenant du titre
les supporters pourront également voir
un entraînement de l'équipe de france
hôte de la compétition l'équipe de
france est première numéro un mondial
l'équipe des états unis oui ça peut nous
convenir bien sûr escale intéressant
c'est qu'il y aura des entraînements
ouverts
donc on pourra faire profiter nos jeunes
sportifs ils pourront côtoyer des
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
aussi très important pour moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas de faire monter la sauce
et le monde déjà rien que de savoir que
les ya un seul entraînement ouvert pour
l'équipe de france et qui se passera à
croissy on aura là du monde largement
autant que l'on veut comme pour l'euro
2016 les équipes évolueront
principalement sur le terrain d'honneur
pendant les sessions d'entraînement dans
le gymnase on retrouvera les vestiaires
ainsi qu'une salle de fitness pour
travailler le renforcement musculaire
un espace sera également dédié à la
presse les aménagements tout effet type
euro 2016 donc a pas de différence si ce
n'est un stade qui est un petit peu plus
large que celui de l'euro 2016 pour
promouvoir dans la ville le football
féminin il cette huitième coupe du monde
des animations seront organisées dans la
ville de croissy sur seine avec
notamment la mise en place d'une fan
zone derrière le terrain d'entraînement
pour suivre les matchs jusqu'au 7
juillet
[Musique]
et je sais que vous l'attendez avec
impatience tous les lundis c'est la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euro bonds soir dans sa galerie tous
les lundis donc vous revenez sur les
résultats sportifs du département
est ce qu'il s'est passé dans le
week-end on parlait football justement
dans ce reportage de vous michael il y
avait du football notamment
c'est ça avec ou à créer la surprise
l'équipe 2 de la commune qui joue en
noir s'est imposé sur la pelouse de
vernal et lors de la 19e journée de
deuxième division de district après
avoir mené 2 à 0 les visiteurs se sont
fait rejoindre à deux partout sur ce
penalty les adriq les hardricourt toi je
vais y arriver profiteront des espaces
en fin de match pour marquer trois buts
sur contre attaque score final 5 à 2 on
écoute les réactions les gars ont
respecté les consignes ce n'était pas un
match facile on s'attendait on savait
qu'on allait avoir une opposition
difficile face à verneuil qui jouait le
haut du tableau mais dans l'ensemble on
voit là les gars ont sorti le match
qu'il fallait quand il fallait
on a manqué un peu de réalisme après ils
ont su nous contrer ils ont été
efficaces
du coup mené 2-0 à la mi-temps donc
difficile mais voilà on a essayé de
pousser ça va pas marcher
après ce match vernet pointe à la
troisième place du classement à deux
journées de la fin du championnat de son
côté un vrai cours en difficulté depuis
le début de la saison respire l'équipe
est désormais 9e et s'éloigne de la zone
de relégation après moi juste comment on
appelle les habitants d'hardricourt
lequel courtoise y est arrivé direction
maintenant les parquets de basket alors
le chesnay-versailles jouer ce week-end
les quarts de finale de playoffs de
prénationale et l'équipe est toujours en
course pour la montée en fin de saison
les yvelinois se sont imposés chez le
basket paris 14 sur le score de 73 à 5
ans 2 et prennent une sérieuse option
avant de disputer le match retour samedi
prochain et les joueurs ne veulent pas
entendre parler de remonta dans les
coudes bombassei l'un des joueurs de
l'équipe de l'entente le chesnay
versailles après
le match est programmé ce samedi soir à
20 heures face au basket paris 14 au
gymnase maubon merci michael tous ces
résultats et bien d'autres choses encore
dans votre émission le 7-8 sport c'est
après ce journal d'abord est-ce que vous
avez l'âme d'un inventeur michael pas
vraiment grégory bon aussi pour ça que
vous ai pas croisé samedi à la
commanderie le lieu d'elancourt
accueillait le village des futurs
insolite professionnels et amateurs se
sont retrouvés autour d'idées futuriste
et loufoque un retour avec marilyn à
pishin au de l'imprimante de portrait en
trois dimensions au jeu interactif
coloré inventeur en tout genre se sont
donné rendez-vous à la commanderie pour
ce tout premier village des futurs
insolite
on est venu présenter quelques grands
vins français c'est une première on est
enthousiaste l'avenir parmi autant de
monde ici
tout juste rentré de la foire de paris
ce kit camping adaptable à tous
véhicules utilitaires attire le public
pouvait les piloter les orienter les
mettre dans le sens que vous voulez
l'hercules c à nouveau pour pouvoir leur
foncer et voilà ce qui vous permet
vraiment de créer des aménagements
nouveau en très peu de temps sans
contrainte et sans outillage
plus loin un réfrigérateur d'extérieur
pour conserver au frais vos livraisons
alimentaires en cas d'absence donc là il
va pouvoir taper un code à 4 chiffres
il ouvre la box
qui est éclairée à l'intérieur et qui
donne une température entre 2 et 4
degrés nous voulions justement permettre
de valoriser les talents du territoire
mais aussi d'ailleurs
à travers différentes thématiques 18
exposants ont répondu présent à l'appel
et les visiteurs et est au rendez vous
on est curieuse et donc nous sommes
venus pour atv attirés par la curiosité
comment un petit enfant de 4 ans on a
voulu lui faire découvrir et puis faire
des activités un peu éducative avec lui
les enfants pouvaient même s'exercer
lors d'ateliers de quoi planter des
idées dans ces petites graines
d'inventeurs mais voilà c'est la fin de
ce set 8 journal replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
dès demain pour une nouvelle édition
belle soirée à tous
[Musique]